اذا اثروا الدول الافريقيه سلبا جراء عدم
الاستقرار في ليبيا خاصه الدول الحدوديه
منها تتدفق الاسلحه والمرتزقه ومختلف
فصائل المعارضه لدول الافريقيه الى صحراء
جنوب ليبيا وتتغدى هذه الدول بالاسلحه
المنطلقه من ليبيا في الثمن من يناير
الجاري وفي الاجتماع التحضيري للمصالحه
الوطنيه الليبيه اكد رئيس الاتحاد
الافريقي رئيس جمهوريه السنغال اكد دعم
الاتحاد لاي حل شامل للازمه في ليبيا
الحديث عن دور المفوضيه الافريقيه في حل
الازمه يسعدنا ان نحب من اديس ابابا
بالبروفيسور محمد الحسن لبابات مدير ديوان
رئيس المفوضيه الافريقيه ورئيس اللجنه
الاستشاريه الافريقيه للمصالحه الوطنيه
الليبيه اهلا بك همم في الح وابدا معك من
المبادئ التي تحكم اا تدخل الاتحاد
الافريقي في المصالحه الليبيه تفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه على النبي
الكريم اا احسنت في البدايه بهذه النقطه
فهي نقطه حاسمه بالغه الاهميه وباختصار
شديد نظرا لضيق الوقت فان هذه المبادئ
يمكن ان نلخصها في اربع نقاط
النقطه الاولى همم المبدا الاول يمكن ان
نسميه وتشبه في الاتحاد الافريقي بمبدا
ضروره حل المشاكل والازمات الافريقيه
بالجهود الافريقيه دون اللجوء الى
التدخلات الاجنبيه بالمعارضه التدخلات
الاجنبيه المبدا الثاني ايضا لحل لهذه
الازمات هو انها لا تحل بالتركي العسكريه
وانما تحل بالتركي السلميه
الثالث وهو انه في طريقه السعي الى ايجاد
ذلك الحل السياسي همم يلزمه انتم شركه كل
الفرقاء في السعي في البحث عن ذلك الحل
يعني اي اقصاء فمبدا رفدي الاقصى في السعي
الى بلوره الحلول السلميه الى الازمات
الافريقيه هو مبدا همم اكيد والمبدا
الرابع هو ضروره وهو مسجل مع المبادئ يعني
بيت الذكر هو مبدا ضروره التملك كل شعب من
الشعوب الافريقيه لماله الوطني والقومي
وبالتالي يكون من هذه من هذا المنطلق دوره
الاتحاد الافريقي مثلا في ملف المصالح
الذي نحن بصدد الحديث يعني
اليس دعما اطلاقا لحل اهله اذا انطلاقه من
هذه المبادئ التي اشرت اليها اربعه تاتي
جهود الاتحاد الافريقي في التركيز على
المصالحه الوطنيه بينما الغرب بشكل عام
تتركز جهوده في الملف السياسي الانتخابات
ربما ايضا توحيد السلطه التنفيذيه هل هناك
تباين او تضارب بين هذه الجهود
قد لا يكون هنالك تضارب بالمعنى الدقيق
الكلمه او الصدامي للكلمه ولكننا نحن نقول
بالمقوله التي نفاذها ان المصالح المصالحه
الوطنيه هي مساله المركزيه في السعي من
اجل الحالي نحن نعتقد انه من باب العبث ان
نتوصل الى
سياسيه تحل الازمه حلا نهائيا ومستديا ما
لم تتم المصالحه لذلك وقد عرفنا عن هذا
الموقف الامم المتحده وللاسره في الليبيين
ونظل حريصين على احترام مركزيه المصالحه
الوطنيه في تاسيسي حلل قابل للبقاء في همم
ليبيا الشقيقه
الى اي همم ماده تعتقدون ان فعلا المصالحه
الوطنيه تلقى هذا القبول في صفوف همم
الاطراف المختلفه خصوصا ان في ملتقى اخير
كان هناك
المصالحه الوطنيه عقده المجلس الرئاسي كان
هناك اختلاف على النشيد والعلم
فاذا كنا في هذا الورد كيف يمكن ان يتوقع
ان يسير هذا الملف قدومه
الاتحاد الافريقي
المشكله من وزير الخارجيه همم الكونغو
التي تتركز اللجنه الربيعيه المستوى للشيخ
الليبي شخصيا متواضع وممثله الاتحاد
الافريقي في ليبيا وغيرها من الشخصيات
الافريقيه ساهمنا في هذا المؤتمر في
اعدادي هذه الاجتماع التحضيري في اعداده
وفي عقده وفي تسيره وفي التصدي لبعده همم
المشاهدات التي حدثت وانا اقول هنا في هذا
الصدر ان مساله همم المسائل الخلافيه التي
يذكر من بينها الخلاف حول العالم والنشيد
هذا حديث المبالغه فيه الى حد كبير فالراي
السائده والذي تم اقراره والذي دافع عنه
الاتحاد الافريقي وان النشيده ولا على مره
هنا يبقى يعني كما هما الى ان يقرر الشعب
اللي اقترا همم على دستور الجديد او
اقتراحات خاصه على المسالتين واما عندها
همم سيتم اقرار ما يصادق عليه الشعب
الليبي ولكن الى ذلك التاريخ يبقى العالم
الراهن ويبقى النشيد الراهب وهذه مساله لم
يكون فيها خلاف كبير واعتقد ان الذين اثار
تساؤلات حول هذه المسالتين في النهايه
اتخذوا مواقف يجد ايجابيه ولصالحه
المصالحه الوطنيه وهذا الشيء يحسب لهم
سياسي وايضا ربما السؤال الاخير عن دور
المبعوثه الافريقي هذه المره المبعوث
افريقيا همم عبد الله باتيلي الى اي حد
يمكن ان يلعب دور في ملفات علاقا مثل
المرتزقه التي ياتي بعضهم من دول افريقيه
كذلك والهجره غير النظاميه التي تمر في
غالبها من ليبيا
بكل تاكيد كمان في المقدمه ليبيا الان هي
تضافر فيها كثير منها عناصر العناصر
السالبه سواء كانت الهجره سواء كانت
عناصر متطرفه سواء كانت لعيب دوليه الى
اخره لمصور احتدام بين المصالح الى اخره
هذا صحيح وفي هذه الظروف ويصبح تعيين
شخصيه افريقيا
جائزه الامم المتحده شيء مشجع بالنسبه
للاتحاد الافريقي والدفاع عنها اليه
والشجعناه لاننا اموري من خلاله ان يكون
هنالك همم شراكه وتعاون همم في الارض على
الارض همم يعكس في التعاونه همم القيم
الذي هو قائم بينه وظيفه الاتحاد الافريقي
اداره الاتحاد الافريقي عامه وهمم الامين
العام للامم المتحده على مستوى همم
المنظمه الدوليه وق انا نقاشات مثمره مع
سيده عبد الله باتليل وصديق شخصي نعرفه
يعرفه قادته همم الاتحاد الافريقي سواء
كان على مستوى الرئاسه الدوليه الدوليه او
على مستوى مفوض المفوضيه وبالتالي
هذا عنصر مشجع واا قد ايه حضر اختتام
لايام التحضيريه للمؤتمر الجامع التي
اقيمت بنجاحنا اخيرا في ليبيا وعندما اقول
نجاح هذا لا يعني
هذا الاجتماع
اشكرك من اديس ابابا البروفيسور محمد
الحسن لبات مدير ديوان رئيس المفوضيه
الافريقيه ورئيس اللجنه الاستشاريه
الافريقيه للمصالحه الوطنيه الليبيه شكرا